a new tax incentive for businesses and
workers could bring relief for many of
the more than forty four million
Americans saddled with student debt
collectively they owe more than one and
a half trillion dollars a truly crushing
amount of money ed O'Keefe is on Capitol
Hill with a proposal that is finding
support from both parties we don't hear
that much these days
good morning when you have for us good
morning Tony the idea is to allow
companies to provide tax free student
loan relief to workers that are paying
off student loan debt it's supported by
hundreds of Democrats and Republicans up
here but like most things that's being
held up by politics that means that
recent college grads looking for help
and the companies willing to provide
relief we're gonna have to wait a little
longer
24-year old Juan Navarro works in the
corporate offices of fairway a chain of
grocery stores based in Iowa he has more
than 19 thousand dollars left to pay on
his student loans it didn't really grasp
until my junior year of college when I
said wow I'm gonna graduate next year
and I'm gonna have all this debt Navarro
is paying down his debt with the help of
fairway the company is giving him
roughly five thousand dollars to help
erase his student loans with this
benefit now I'm able to save money on
interest and also to get rid of my
student loan debt quicker but the
benefit is taxed so fairway and Navarre
are waiting for Congress to sweeten the
deal currently a company can contribute
up to five thousand two hundred fifty
dollars tax-free
each year for tuition assistance helping
workers who are attending classes while
on the job but no such tax break exists
to help workers who are paying off
student loans on degrees they've already
earned a bill working its way through
Congress would let companies do just
that neither the company nor the
employee would pay any tax on the money
so far companies like Starbucks Verizon
and hewlett-packard support the
legislation the athletic company New
Balance said in a statement that if the
bill passes the company will introduce a
student loan repayment benefit all we
are waiting for is federal legislation
this gives a a win for the student and a
win for the employer Democratic Senator
Mark Warner and Republican John Thune
are lead sponsors of the bill that would
provide the tax break so many students
who go to our best colleges in universe
he's worked really hard to get a degree
and then they come out and trade in
their cap and gown for a mountain of
debt and uncertainty the idea is backed
by more than two dozen other senators
and more than 140 members of the House
but in the Senate it'll need to pass as
part of a larger tax bill that's yet to
be introduced some critics warn that
while popular the incentive would
encourage more borrowing and higher
education costs in the long run the
worst thing we could do is say even more
to students someone else is gonna pay
that debt not you why not focus instead
on compelling or forcing colleges and
universities to just charge less I think
that's got to be part of the solution
it's not gonna solve every problem as
Mark pointed out but we think it's
realistic we think it's something that
could pass even in a place as
dysfunctional as Washington this one
should be a no-brainer
Navaro says the repayment benefit he's
already receiving has changed his life
I'm a little less stressed a little more
excited for my future work and holds as
far as I will be out of debt sooner late
last night we got word that this
legislation has support from Ivanka
Trump someone known to have a little
sway with her father she said in a
statement to CBS News that she and her
team believe this legislation will have
a transformative effect on the students
entering the workforce as well as
workers seeking to advance their careers
we hope that Congress can set its
differences aside and provide solutions
Anthony
so it if there's support from the White
House now what exactly is the holdup
well like we said there and this is a
tricky thing it has to be part of a
broader piece of legislation that deals
with some changes to tax law there is
one in the works we'll see exactly when
later this year it gets passed but you
know this is a good sign
there are some proposals from
presidential candidates to basically
relieve all student debt this is a
signal from both parties at least in
Congress that this might be a more
realistic first step it's nice they can
agree on something and thank you